MEMBER CARILLO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BONTA BROUGH BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA. RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
OTHER MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN US ON THE FLOOR.
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR
MEMBERS SO WE MAY. ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. THE REQUIREMENTS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
REVEREND. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. RECENTLY
A VERY TECHIE FRIEND HELPED US
SET UP OUR NEW FLAT SCREEN TV.
ONCE DONE HE SAID NOW WITH
STREAMING ENTERTAINMENT YOU CAN
GET ANY MOVIE ANY SONG ANY BOOK
IN THE SPORTING EVENT ON ANY
ADVICE ON DEVICE ON IN AT ANY
TIME. WITH ENTHUSIASM HE ADDED
NOW THE WORLD IS AT YOUR
FINGERTIPS. AS HE SPOKE THESE
WORDS I THOUGHT WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY THE MOST WELL
ENTERTAIN PEOPLE THAT HAVE EVER
LIVED. I DO APPRECIATE
TECHNOLOGY BUT AS OUR
ENTERTAINMENT OPTIONS CONTINUE
TO GROW. WELL WE'VE BECOME A
NATION OF VIEWERS INSTEAD OF
DOERS. IS THIS STREAMING
TECHNOLOGY CREATING EVEN MORE A
SPECTATOR CULTURE. ALTHOUGH IT
MAY SEEM THAT THE WORLD IS AT
OUR FINGERTIPS WE MUST REMAIN A
NATION OF DOERS AND NOT BECOME
A NATION OF VIEWERS. LIFE IS
NOT VIRTUAL THERE IS NO RESET
BUTTON ON LIFE IN OUR DAYS CAN
NEVER BE RELIVED. AS WE ENJOY
OUR TECHNOLOGY LET US ALSO
REMAIN ENGAGED IN THE REAL
WORLD APPRECIATING EACH
WONDROUS DAY. NOW MOMMY KNOWN
SOON BUT KINDA IN GRAD BEYOND
WERE. THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
MAY. ALREADY BE IN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. STATES
OR- AND THIS IS. WHICH IS AN.
IS. YES OUR- THANK YOU BE
SEATED. WE OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH TWENTY TWENTY THIS
ONLY MET AT SEVEN AM ANIMAL
RANDY VOEPEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVENTY FIRST DISTRICT
PRESIDING CHIEF CLICKS YOU
PARKER AT THE DESK REINSURER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR FLORA
SECONDS. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LEMOND AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARIE WALDRON FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
BERMAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS SKEWS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SOME
MEMBERS GALLAGHER HOLDEN IRWIN
IN THIS AREA TO SPEAK ON THE
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS IF I GET
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS WE
HAVE A VERY SPECIAL GUEST WITH
US. ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TODAY
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION AND
PRESENTATION MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AT THE PLEASURE TO HAVE
WITH US TODAY. I'M HONORED TO
INTRODUCE A TWO TIME GRAMMY
AWARD WINNING JAZZ ARTISTS
GREGORY PORTER AND HIS WIFE
VICTORIA AND THEIR FAMILY
THAT'S HERE WITH US TODAY SIX
TIME NOMINEE I GREW UP IN
BAKERSFIELD WHERE IS MOTHER
RUTH WAS A MINISTER SHE
INSTILLED IN HIM LESSONS OF
GIVING AND KINDNESS AND
ENCOURAGE GREGORY TO NEVER GIVE
UP ON MUSIC. FROM EARLY ON HE
LOVE LISTENING TO THAT KING
COLD OUT WE ALL. WALL GOING
THROUGH HIS MOTHER'S RECORD
COLLECTION. IMITATING HIM AND
DEVELOPING IS GREAT MUSICAL
TALENTS BURGER WAS ALSO A
GIFTED FOOTBALL PLAYER AND
GRADUATED FROM HIGHLAND HIGH
SCHOOL. WITH A FOOTBALL
SCHOLARSHIP TO SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. WILL LIKELY FOR
JAZZ FANS HE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM FOOTBALL AND INTO MUSIC.
AFTER MOVING TO BROOKLYN
GREGORY WORKED AS A CHEF A
PERFORMING IN JAZZ CLUBS AT
NIGHT. DURING THIS TIME IS
MEANT HE MET HIS MENTOR. AND
BEGAN APPEARING IN JAZZ ALBUMS
EVEN BECAME THE LEAD OF THE
BROADWAY MUSICAL IT AIN'T
NOTHIN BUT THE BLUES. GREGORY
ROSE TO A CLAIM WITH THIS FIRST
ALBUM IN TWENTY TEN TITLED
WATER. AND WAS CRITICALLY
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS EARTHY CROSS
POLLINATED BRAND OF JAZZ SOUL
AND GOSPEL MUCH LIKE. THE GREAT
THAT CAN CALL. HIS SECOND ALBUM
BE GOOD FURTHER SHOWCASED
GREGORY'S GROWING PROMINENCE
AND HIS THIRD ALBUM LIQUID
SPIRIT HIT NUMBER TWO ON THE
JAZZ CHARTS AND WON THE TWENTY
FOURTEEN GRAMMY FOR BEST JAZZ
VOCAL ALBUM OF THE YEAR. HE WON
A SECOND GRAMMY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH HIS NEXT ALBUM
TAKE ME TO THE ALLEY. LIQUID
SPIRIT HAS SINCE BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST STREAMED JAZZ ALBUMS
OF ALL TIME. WITH TWENTY
MILLION STREAMS. ALL THROUGHOUT
HIS MUSICAL CAREER GREGORY HAS
MADE A LASTING IMPRESSION ON
MILLIONS OF FANS AND THROUGH
PHILANTHROPY GIVING VARIOUS
CHARITABLE PERFORMANCES. FOR
HIS FIRST CONCERT AT
BAKERSFIELD ALL PROCEEDS WENT
TO HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND
TWENTY NINETEEN GREGORY GAVE AN
UNPLUGGED CONCERT AT TO SUPPORT
A GAP A LAND ACADEMY THE LOCAL
SCHOOL NEAR WHERE HE GREW UP.
HE HAS INSISTED THAT ALL HIS
LOCAL SHOWS BENEFIT CHARITABLE
CAUSES I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT
MUCH LIKE NAT KING COLE DID FOR
HIM GREGORY IS ALREADY
INSPIRING THE NEXT GENERATION
OF GREAT JAZZ ARTISTS. I'M SO
EXCITED TO SEE WHAT HE
ACCOMPLISHED OF NEXT BOTH THE
MUSIC AND IN OUR COMMUNITY. AB
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MISTER GREGORY PORTER
VICTORIAN AS FAMILY CONFIRMED.
CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR WHEREVER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS AND-
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ITO
WANT TO CELEBRATE OF THE YOUNG
MAN TODAY HE'S A FORMER STUDENT
OF MINE AT THE UNIVERSITY. AND
ALONG WITH AN AWFUL LOT OF OFF
A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE UNIVERSITY MEETING
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE THE
AFRICANA STUDIES DEPARTMENT
EMBRACE THEM AND HE HAS MADE US
SO PROUD OF AS ONE OF MY
STUDENTS AND HE WAS MY TO MY
KIDS ONE OF MY KIDS AND SO IT'S
AMAZING WHEN I SEE HIM AND WHAT
HE'S DOING NOW. AND OBVIOUSLY
THE MESSAGES WE GAVE TO THEM
ABOUT BEING PROUD ABOUT
PRODUCING THINGS THAT REALLY
CHANGED THE WORLD AND MAKING AN
IMPACT IS THERE AND SO I'M
HONORED AS A TEACHER AS A
PROFESSOR TO WELCOME YOU TO
THIS HOUSE- ALL OF THE WORK I
DO IS A REFLECTION OF YOU AND I
LOVE YOU DEARLY.
OKAY MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AC ARE. ONE
FIFTY SIX BY MISTER COOPER. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO ROSA
PARKS DAY. MEMBERS. MISTER
COOPER ON THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TODAY TO RISE HELLO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
COMMEMORATE IMMORTALIZED ONE OF
AMERICA'S GREATEST CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS MRS ROSA PARKS MEMBERS
ACR ONE FIVE SIX DECLARES
DEBRIS FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY AS
THE TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
ROSA PARKS DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BORN ON FEBRUARY
FOURTH NINETEEN THIRTEEN MRS
PARKS BELATED BE DEEMED THE
PATRON SAINT AND ONE OF
AMERICA'S PIONEERS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AFTER SHE
REFUSED TO GIVE UP HER SEAT. ON
A BUS FOR A WHITE MAN RESULTING
IN HER ARREST WHISPERED THE
BEGINNING OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT OUR THAT HISTORIC DAY
ROSA PARKS DEDICATED HER ENTIRE
LIFE HUMAN RIGHTS AND EQUALITY
FOR ALL ON FRIDAY FEBRUARY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND LEGISLATURE
OF CELEBRATED ROSE A PART A ON
A- FOR ACHIEVING AS MAY TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO AMERICAN CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. IF YOU'RE SIX
CREW RATES THE TWENTY TEN.
OTHERS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER MISTER GIBSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT ACR ONE
FIFTY SIX OF FORCE TODAY I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS ACR TO
COMMEMORATE THE LIFE THE LEGACY
OF A ROSA PARKS I REMEMBER ROSA
PARKS AND SHE CAME TO LOS
ANGELES AT THE BEHEST OF OR AT
THE REQUEST OF ONE OF MY GOOD
FRIENDS. WAS PURSUED THE END
DOUBLE THE P. I'M CHAPTER
PRESIDENT AND IT WAS REMARKABLE
BEING IN HER PRESENCE- ROSA
PARKS REFUSED TO GIVE UP HER
SEAT NOT BECAUSE SHE WAS TIRED.
BUT BECAUSE SHE WAS TIRED OF
GIVING IN. SHE'S THE UP A
PRINCIPLES AND SOMETIME MEMBERS
WE HAVE TO SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER
AND CERTAINLY ROSA PARKS DID
JUST THAT.BY SITTING DOWN SHE
STOOD UP FOR JUSTICE IN AMERICA
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT
I VOTE ON AC ARE ONE FIFTY SIX
REMEMBER THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF
ROSA PARKS. THANK YOU MS GIBSON
IS RAMOS YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A C.
R. ONE FIVE SIX WHICH HONORS
AND COMMEMORATES THE LATE TO
ROSA PARKS AND PROVIDE A VITAL
ROLE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. PERHAPS THE MOST
INSPIRING ASPECTS OF ROSA PARKS
RESISTANCE TO ME WAS HER
READINESS TO HEED THE CALL AND
MAKE THE SACRIFICE TO PROTEST
ON JUST JIM CROW LAWS. IN
REVEREND KING'S OWN WORDS MRS
PARKS WAS IDEAL FOR THE ROLE
ASSIGNED TO HER BY HISTORY.
BECAUSE OUR HER CHARACTER WAS
IMPECCABLE AND HER DEDICATION
DEEP ROOTED. SHE WAS UNAFRAID
OF THE DIFFICULT ROLE SHE WOULD
PLAY IN CREEK CREATING
HISTORICAL CHANGE. HER
DEDICATION TO JUSTICE WAS
UNSHAKABLE EVEN IN THE FACE OF
DANGER. AS OUR OWN REVEREND
PATTY TOLD US THIS MORNING ARE
WE GOING TO BE A NATION OF
YOURS OR NATION OF DOORS. ROSA
PARKS WAS A DOER BECAUSE OF
THIS I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD TO
HAVE A HISTORIC STEP TO SELL
CELEBRATING THE LIFE AND WORKS
OF ROSA PARKS IN MY DISTRICT IN
ADDITION TO THE ROSA PARKS
MEMORIAL STATE BUILDING AND SO
I WISH MRS PARKS A HAPPY
BELATED BIRTHDAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DAVIS RAYOS DOCTOR WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I TO RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND THANKING OUR MEMBER
MISTER COOPER. FOR BRINGING
THIS PARTICULAR ACR FORWARD. IT
IS BE FITTING THAT AS WE BEGIN
THE MONTH OF BLACK HISTORY THAT
WE LOOK AT SOMEONE LIKE ROSA
PARKS AS AN EXAMPLE OF AN
ORDINARY PERSON DOING AN
EXTRAORDINARY THING. THAT SHE
BASICALLY HELPED US BEGIN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ERA IN THIS
NATION. AND DIED WE CELEBRATE
HER BECAUSE OF THAT IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED THAT SHE DID THIS NOT
BECAUSE SHE WAS TIRED OF OUT.
JUST TIRED LEAD TO MORE TIRED
THAN ANY OF THE TIME AND FACTOR
BIOGRAPHY SHE TALKS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THERE WAS NOTHING
REALLY THAT UNIQUE ABOUT THE
DAY. THAT SHE HAD BEEN TIRED
AND WE LEARNED SOME OF THEM
FANNIE LOU HAMER THAT
OFTENTIMES BLACK PEOPLE ARE
TIRED OF BEING SICK AND TIRED
OF BEING SICK AND TIRED. THAT
THE ISSUE OF EXHAUSTION FROM
RACISM IS SOMETIMES SO
OVERWHELMING THAT IT MAKES YOU
BETTER AND TIRED AND SOMETIMES
PARALYZED IN TERMS OF YOUR
ABILITY TO ACT. SO IT IS
FORTUNATE FOR US THAT SHE DID
NOT ALLOW HER HER ANGER AND HER
CONCERN ABOUT THE DIGNITY AND
BEING EXPECTED TO BASICALLY
MOVED IN THAT DIRECTION. YOU
KNOW REPRESENTS AND MANY IS THE
EXAMPLE LOTS OF VISUAL WORK THE
SOME THEY ARE. AT THE END.
TIRED OF BEING A- WHO WAS NOT
OF C<c.cyan>. THE ISSUE HER BAY.</c>
BEING AN OLD WOMAN AND SHE WAS
NOT SHE WAS IN HER EARLY
FORTIES AT THE TIME- SHE WAS A
WOMAN WHO WAS EDUCATED AND YET
HAD LIVED IN A SOCIETY THAT DID
NOT RESPECT TO EDUCATION. AND
THEREFORE COULD NOT GET A
PROFESSIONAL JOB AND WORKED AS
A SEAMSTRESS AS A RESULT OF
THAT. WE ALSO DON'T DON'T OFTEN
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT SHE WAS
A DISRUPTOR AND ACTIVISTS. SHE
WORK FOR THE IN DOUBLE ACP SHE
UNDERSTOOD THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HER BE HERE. AND SHE WAS
WILLING TO BASICALLY STAND UP
WHEN SO MANY OTHERS NOT WILLING
TO STAND UP. AND FIGHT FOR WHAT
WAS RIGHT SHE KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN SO MANY OTHERS HAVE DONE
THE SAME. IT MAY BE TO PUT
TAKEN OFF THE LIST THEY WOULD
BE INCARCERATED MAYBE SOMETIMES
BEATEN. THEY WAS. WAS AND JUST.
EXAMPLE OF MEAT HAPPEN AND ALL
OF THE WOMEN SO MAY. WHEN WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. WHO WHAT
BASICALLY MOVE FORWARD. MY
FRIEND'S MOTHER WAS A PART OF
HER GRANDMOTHER WAS A PART OF
THE MONTGOMERY BUS BOYCOTT. AND
THEY OFTEN TALKED ABOUT HOW.
THOSE WOMEN IN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS STOOD EVERY DAY FOR
THIRTEEN MONTHS WAITING AND
WALKING TO WORK. MILES AND
MILES OF WORK. THAT THEY WALKED
BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO RIDE THE
BUS. THEY TOOK THEY TOOK A
STAND THAT WAS IT INCONVENIENT
POSITION FOR THEM. WE OFTEN
THINK OF IT AS BEING MAYBE ROCK
WILL ORGANIZE AND THEY HAD CARS
AT ALL THOSE THINGS TO TAKE
PEOPLE TO WORK. AND THAT HE
ACTUALLY EVOLVED INTO THAT.
WHAT THEIR DESIRE TO NOT TAKE
THE BUS. WAS ONE THAT WAS
PERSONAL. IT WAS SACRIFICIAL
BUT THEY WERE DETERMINED. AND
I'VE TALKED TO SO MANY ELDERS I
WAS DOING SO BY WORK IN
RESEARCH AND CIVIL RIGHTS.THAT
WERE PART OF THAT THEY WALK AND
THEY OFTEN WALKED. THROUGHS
THEY CARRY. THAT WALK ALL THE
PLACES THAT WOULD NOT WELL
PAID. BUT NONE THE LESS THEY
WERE DETERMINED TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT THEY WOULD. RIDE
THE BUS THAT THEY WERE TIRED OF
BEING. L. L. INSULTED AND
HAVING THEIR DIGNITY TAKEN
AWAY. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
ROSA PARKS AND WE TALK ABOUT
ALL THE STUFF RIGHTS.
INDIVIDUAL WE SHOULD BE. HIGHER
I AT LEAST IN STE. BY CHAP. THE
THEY TOOK. I ALSO USED TO TELL
MY- ABOUT MY- JOURNEY USED. A
AND- I WOULD OFTEN CONTENT. AND
DRIVE UP THE HILL. TO THE- BUS.
EVERY DAY I SEE THESE QUOTES
ROSE UP. WAY BEING OFF OF THE
BUS. WHO WOULD I WOULD APPROACH.
X. WALK THOSE LAWS AT BAY TO GO
IN SOMEBODY ELSE. HOUSE AND IN
OUR RIGHTS HE'S LOS ANGELES IS
THE SEAL. AND THEY WOULD DO
EVERY DAY. THEY WANT TO CHECK
IN. BASIC REVENUE. STOP THEM A
LOT AND GIVE HIM A RIDE HE'LL-
NAY WHAT I SAY ME. LITTLE GIRL
YOU WILL BE SOMEBODY THAT'S WHY
WE'RE DOING WE DO. AND THEY MAY
HAVE BEEN TIRED THEY NEVER
STOPPED. AND I ALWAYS MYSELF
YOU KNOW IT LOOKS I'M- BEEN
DOING SOME. BUT I HAVE A MY
THAT I MADE BUSY AND I MAY BE
OVER. BUT I'LL NEVER TIRED. I
WOULD NEVER LIE THE WAY OF THIS
WORLD TO DETERMINE THE FACT
THAT I WILL NOT STAND AND I
WILL NOT FIGHT. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN HAVE THIS EXAMPLE OF
PEOPLE IN AFRICAN AMERICANS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. WHO
FLOCKED TO GIVE THEIR CHILDREN
AN OPPORTUNITY WHO FOUGHT TO
GIVE THEM AN EDUCATION WILL
FLOCK TO OPEN DOORS AND WE
STAND ON THEIR SHOULDERS EVERY
TIME. WE FIGHT FOR WHAT IS
RIGHT AND JUST. AS WE APPROACH
AB THREE NINE TWO LAST YEAR. I
HAD TO REMEMBER ALL OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THEY DO
SHOULD FREIGHT. THINGS COULD
HAPPEN TO YOU AND I SAID I'M
NOT THE COURAGEOUS ONE. THEY
WERE THE COURAGEOUS ONES
BECAUSE THINGS COULD HAVE
REALLY HAPPENED TO THEM. AND WE
STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF FOLKS
WHO PLANTED THE SEED ON THE
GROUND FREEDOM AND WE'RE
DETERMINED TO MOVE THE AGENDA.
AND MOST OF US WE THINK ABOUT
IT WE DON'T HAVE TO SACRIFICE A
WHOLE LOT THE STATE WHAT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT IS PASSED. AND
THIS NOW WE NEED PEOPLE STAND
WE NEED THOSE WHO HAVE TAKEN
THE CHALLENGE AND KNOW WHAT'S
RIGHT AND WHAT IS JUST.
COULDN'T TO THE FUTURE. AT NO.
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE RESULT OF
HER TAKING THE STATE AND- WHICH-
CHANGE THE CHAIN THE COLOR. OF
THE SO. TO CHANGE THE ISSUES
ARE THE LOS THIS LAND. AND THIS
SIMPLE. THIS STILL ORDER PER.
TAKING ON AN EXTRA. CHALLENGE
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN ALL OF OUR
LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR ACR. ONE THIRTY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER. THIS
COOPER THE AUTHOR IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG. NEVER CEASES FOR CALL
AUTHORS ON A C. R. ONE FIVE SIX
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS WORK
WELL. CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ALL SET THEIR READING FILE ITEM
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN. CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS A MEMBER WAS
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE RECOVERY THE SECOND A
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK RELATIVE TO SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY WEEK CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ROLE I SEVENTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FIVE I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SIX I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY EIGHT AYE AYES SEVENTY
FIVE. NO ZERO. ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TODAY. MR STONE REMINDS US AT
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING UPON A GERMAN IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM THAT'S
JUDICIARY UPON A GERMAN IN THE
ROLES ROOM. MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
YOU THAT WEAR RED DAY. IN HONOR
OF AMERICAN HEART MONTH WILL BE
THIS UPCOMING MONDAY FEBRUARY
TENTH THIS UPCOMING MONDAY
FEBRUARY TEN IS WEAR RED DAY
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECKING
SESSION MONDAY. FEBRUARY TENTH
THE FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR- TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO
WILL BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY.
OR PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
OR REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE MR GALLAGHER A LITTLE BIT
OF ROOM. WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
RANA PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS. IN MEMORY. WE
WILL COME BACK TO MR GALLAGHER.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS OF
I RISE TO DURING THE MEMORY OF
TED SHAW ALSO KNOWN AS MISTER
SOUTH PASADENA WHO PASSED AWAY
ON FEBRUARY FIRST AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY FIVE BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR AND REYES AND SOUTH
PASADENA TED SHAW WAS
CONSIDERED BY MANY TO BE A
HOMETOWN BOY TURNED LOCAL
LEGEND. SHAW WAS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN SOUTH
PASADENA BUT ALSO A CIVIC
LEADER FORMER MAYOR AND
PHILANTHROPISTS WHO SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR WHAT FOR FILLING
YOUR CIVIC DUTY TRULY MEANS.
DOES CO FOUNDER OF CHAU MOSES
MINUTES ALL AGENCY AND
INSURANCE BROKERAGE THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF MANY OF THE NEWER COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. ALONG THE MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES AND SOUTH
PASADENA. HE ALSO HELPED START
THE CITY'S FOURTH OF JULY
FESTIVAL OF BALLOONS. AND THE
SOUTH PASADENA RELAY FOR LIFE.
WHICH REYES SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY. A
PERSON WHO ALWAYS PUT HIS WIFE
AND CHILDREN FIRST. SHAW WAS AT
THE HEART A FAMILY MAN. KNOWN
AS AN EXAMPLE FIGHT HOMETOWN
HERO. TED SHAW EMBODIED OR ROLE
MODEL FOR CIVIC PRIDE THROUGH
HIS PHILANTHROPY AND ACTIONS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA. THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA WILL MISS THEM AND SO
ALIVE. THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I'D-
ASKED THAT WE CLOSE IN MEMORY
OF JACKIE CHANDLER. JACKIE
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY SIXTH
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY SHE WAS
NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD. SHE WAS
BORN ON MARCH TENTH NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE IN KERN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA JACQUI GRADUATED
FROM UCLA IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX
AND BEGAN HER TEACHING CAREER.
SECOND GRADE WAS HER FAVORITE
WHICH TOOK HER TO MONTEREY
CALIFORNIA. WELL AS LEE AND
THEN BACK TO CALIFORNIA WHERE
SHE HAD BEEN ACCEPTED FOR
GRADUATE SCHOOL AT UC BERKELEY.
IT WAS THERE THAT A BLIND DATE
LED HER TO HER FUTURE HUSBAND.
ROGER CHANDLER A CHARMING YOUNG
FARMER FROM SUTTER COUNTY. AND
SOON THEY WERE MARRIED ON JUNE
ELEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY NINE
THE TWO STARTED THEIR LIFE
TOGETHER ON A FARM A NEW ASTRO
ROAD IN JACQUI CONTINUED HER
TEACHING CAREER AND LOCAL
SCHOOLS INCLUDING NEW ASTRO
TERRIBLE INTO. AND WALTER KIND
NACH. TOGETHER JACQUI ROGER
SHARED THE MANY BLESSINGS. OF A
GOOD MARRIAGE. JACKIE LOVE LIFE
AND ESPECIALLY HER FAMILY HER
FRIENDS TENNIS TRAVEL THE
GIANTS. AND THE SYMPHONY BUS TO
THE CITY SHE HAD SPARKLE DRIVE
AND DETERMINATION. SHE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE AND THE
FIRST PUBLICITY CHAIR OF THE
RIDE OUT HOSPITAL EXHILARATING
ALSO KNOWN AS THE PINK LADIES
AND WAS THE FIRST CHAIRPERSON
OF THAT GROUP SERIES OF LOCAL
CHILDREN'S PLAY IS. SHE TAUGHT
SUNDAY SCHOOL AT SAINT JOHN'S
EPISCOPAL CHURCH WHERE SHE
SERVED AS THE ALTAR GUILD
JACKIE WAS ACTIVE IN THE YUBA
CITY HIGH SCHOOL PTA. AN ARDENT
MEMBER OF THE GAMMA CHAPTER
ALPHA SIGMA SORORITY. SHE WAS A
STEADFAST WIFE LOVING MOM AND
GRANDMOTHER AND A GOOD AND
LOYAL FRIEND TO MANY. SHE WAS
FROM EDIBLE ON THE TENNIS
COURT. AND ALMOST UNBEATABLE AT
DOMINO'S DINNER AT JACKIE'S
WHETHER A FORMAL EXTRAVAGANZA
OR A SPUR OF THE MOMENT
HAPPENING WAS ALWAYS A WONDER.
IN HER OWN OFTEN REPEATED WORDS
JACKIE HAD A GREAT LIFE. JACKIE
IS SURVIVED BY TWO SONS OF ONE
OF OUR FORMER COLLEAGUES. REYES
CHANDLER AND- OF YUBA CITY AND
DR CHARLES CHANDLER OF LOS
ANGELES. SHE IS ALSO SURVIVED
BY SIXGRANDCHILDREN AND EIGHT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. MEMBERS
ASKED THAT WE CLOSE IN MEMORY
OF JACKIE CHAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS GALLAGHER. MS IRWIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO ADJOURN AND THE MEMORY OF
OXNARD POLICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICER NATHAN MARTIN. WHO DIED
IN A MOTORCYCLE CRASH AS HE WAS
LEAVING FOR WORK ON JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH. OFFICER MARTIN A
TWENTY YEAR VETERAN OF THE
FORCE WAS A PATROL OFFICER
TRAFFIC OFFICER PROPERTY CRIMES
INVESTIGATOR. FIELD TRAINING
OFFICER AND POLICE ACADEMY
INSTRUCTOR PRIOR TO BEING
ASSIGNED TO BE A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER AT MY KNEE
HIGH SCHOOL. IT WAS ALSO A
LIAISON FOR THE CRIME STOPPERS
THE COUNTY WIDE NONPROFIT TIP
LINE. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
SENSE OF HUMOR AND POSITIVE
ATTITUDE IS A GRADUATE OF REAL
MESA HIGH SCHOOL AND AN EAGLE
SCOUT. NATHAN LOVED THE PEOPLE
OF OXNARD HE LOVED WHINY HIGH
SCHOOL. WHERE HE HELPED COACH
VOLLEYBALL HE LOVED TO SERVE
AND PROTECT OFFICER MARTIN WAS
BILINGUAL IN SPANISH AND SERVED
AS AN INSTRUCTOR IN THE POLICE
PROGRAM THAT OFFERED HELP TO
PARENTS OF CHILDREN SHOWING
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS. HE WAS A
FAMILY MAN WHO IS ACTIVE IN HIS
CHURCH. OFFICER MARTIN LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE MORITA AS WELL
AS HIS CHILDREN TWENTY YEAR OLD
GABRIEL SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
SHARIAH AND FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
DAVID. HE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY
HIS MOTHER SUSAN AND HIS
BROTHER OF FELLOW OXNARD POLICE
OFFICER TOM MARTIN. I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF NAY
TH AND MARK. THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN MR IS AREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT
TODAY I RISE TO ASK FOR THIS
BODY TO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DETECTIVE AMBER JOY LIST WHO
DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
JANUARY TWELFTH. FOR THOSE WHO
KNEW AMBER SHE BROUGHT MUCH JOY
TO THEIR LIVES. RIGHT FUNNY AND
SHE LOVED PEOPLE. SHE WAS KNOWN
FOR HAVING IMPECCABLE PEOPLE
SKILLS AND POSSESS A HIGH LEVEL
OF EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE A
SKILL THAT NO DOUBT SERVED HER
IN HER CAREER WELL. AMBER
STARTED HER CAREER AS A RECRUIT
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. AND WITH
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION WORKED
HER WAY UP TO A SHARE OF. LAST
MONTH- AMBER WAS STRUCK AND
KILLED. BY A VEHICLE ON THE
STREET WHILE SHE WAS OFF DUTY
ON A SUNDAY MORNING. STOPPED AT
A RED LIGHT SHE SAW AN ELDERLY
COUPLE OF. MOVING ALONG THE
LINE IN A PEDESTRIAN OF MOVING
ALONG THE TRAFFIC AND THE
WEAPON ONE OF THE UP- COUPLE
ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS FELL.
AND THE OTHER COULD NOT HELP OF
THEIR SPOUSE UP SHE LEFT HER
CAR GOT OUT. PICKED UP THE
GENTLEMAN MOVED HIM ACROSS AND
ONCE MADE SURE THAT HE HAD
SAFELY PASSED CAME BACK TO HER
CAR. AND IN THAT MOMENT A
FLURRY SHE WAS STRUCK AND
KILLED. SHE WAS A TWIT TWELVE
YEAR VETERAN OF THE LOS ANGELES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. AMBER
LEAVES BEHIND HER PARENTS
DANIEL AND ELLEN LIST. THREE
SISTERS HEATHER SUMMARY AND
SAVANNAH. TWO SONS TWENTY YEAR
OLD RATE LANEY WHO'S CURRENTLY
SERVING IN THE US NAVY AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD DANIEL LANEY.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN. YOU
ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADDITIONAL GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
TODAY I RISE THAT THIS BODY TO
JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF HOW GO MY
GKN AGO WAS A VERY KIND AND
GENTLE SOUL- WHO- WAS MANY
THINGS TO MANY PEOPLE WAS A
WONDERFUL FATHER OF ONE DEVOTED
HUSBAND OF. A GREAT GRANDFATHER
OF BUT ALSO. HE WAS OF THE
GENERATION HAVING BEEN BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR. IN A
SMALL VILLAGE IN SYRIA HE WAS
OF THE GENERATION THAT SURVIVE
WHOSE PARENTS HAD SURVIVED THE
GENOCIDE. AND SO HE COMMITTED
HIS LIFE TO ADVANCING THE
ARMENIAN CAUSE AND TO ENSURING.
THAT THE- GROUP THE ETHNIC
GROUP CONTINUES TO SURVIVE AND
THRIVE. AFTER THE HORRIFIC
EXPERIENCES THAT HIS PARENTS.
HAD GONE THROUGH HI GROUP MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA IN EARLY NINETEEN
FIFTIES. WHERE HE STARTED HIS
OWN BUSINESS ARMOR MACHINE
COMPANY IN SOUTH GATE.
CALIFORNIA IS IN TO MAKE
PRECISION PARTS FOR OIL
EXPLORATION MACHINERY AND
AEROSPACE ENABLE INDUSTRIES.
BUT AFTER FIVE O'CLOCK THAT'S
WHEN HIS REAL WORK BEGAN THAT'S
WHEN HE TOILED AWAY IN MAKING
SURE THAT THERE WERE VARIOUS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
ESTABLISHED CHURCHES SCHOOLS
PLACES OF- GATHERING SO THAT
THE COMMUNITY REBOUNDS AND WE
COLLECTS. AND MAKES PROGRESS
AFTER THE HORRIFIC EVENTS OF
THE GENOCIDE. I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF GETTING TO KNOW OF
MISTER MIND YOU CAN AND THE-
THE BOOKS THAT HE HAD HELP
PRINT AND THE- HELP IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE BOOKS THAT HE
PRINTED ALONG WITH HIS WIFE CAN
ARE. WERE PLACED IN THE STATE
LIBRARY JUST SOME YEARS AGO.
DON'T THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE- LIKE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF UP MISTER
MIND YOU CAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAIN A
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE SEEING
AND HEARING OF FOR THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MISTER DAVID CHIU
MOVES AND MISTER NAZARIAN
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY FEBRUARY
TENTH. AT ONE PM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.